NICK BUTCHER: And welcome to
this week's edition of Android
Developers Office Hours.
So coming to you live
from London, my
name is Nick Butcher.
And I'm joined by--
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Richard
Hyndman.
MATT GAUNT: And Matt Gaunt.
NICK BUTCHER: And as usual, this
is your chance to ask us,
the Android Developer Relations
and Google TV
Relations any Android
development or
GTV development questions.
As usual, this is not a forum
for announcing new products or
commenting on launch
dates [INAUDIBLE]
and so forth.
So unforunately, we will
not be able to
comment on those things.
But yeah.
Any questions or discussions
about an Android development,
this is the place.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Yes,
Carlos from Madrid.
That was aimed at you.
NICK BUTCHER: I always call
those preempted--
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Preempted
[INAUDIBLE]
question asking something
that we're not going to.
Sorry about that.
NICK BUTCHER: We have a usual
suspects live in the Hangout.
So I see Hugo, [? Yossi, ?]
and is that [? Tal? ?]
[? TAL: Yeah, ?] that's me.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: We've got two
people on phones this week.
That's what happens when it
gets close to Christmas.
NICK BUTCHER: How are
you doing, guys?
TAL: I am good.
I am not on the phone.
I am on the computer.
NICK BUTCHER: OK.
Any exciting Android
development
news you want to discuss?
I think we just had the--
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Yeah.
Absolutely.
The Play Store team, some of
which are based out of London,
just popped their heads through
the curtain here to
say that they've just flipped
the switch, pressed the
button, and launched the feature
that is expansion
files on the new Google Play
Developer Console.
So is that the last point,
the last one that--
NICK BUTCHER: No.
Multi APK.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Multi APK
[? is still not ?]
available.
NICK BUTCHER: Oh, yes.
Hopefully a lot of you have
used the new and improved
developer site.
You should hopefully be
enjoying its better
organization, and response to
design and all this good stuff
on the new [? hub ?] site.
So yeah.
Slowly moving all the features
from the old site into the
new, better designed site.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: And now it
supports expansion files.
TAL: I heard, also, something
about YouTube, right?
YouTube API and [INAUDIBLE],
something like that.
NICK BUTCHER: I heard
this too.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Excellent.
Can you tell us more
about that?
NICK BUTCHER: [INAUDIBLE]
API, right?
TAL: There is a new version
of the YouTube API.
I didn't get to check
it out here.
Just wanted to know if you know
something about that.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: [INAUDIBLE]
Google I/O?
NICK BUTCHER: No, it's
not an Android thing.
It's just a YouTube API thing.
MATT GAUNT: Yeah.
YouTube API thing.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Yeah.
You can go to the YouTube
developer office hours, at
developers.google.com/live.
But, yeah.
The new YouTube API is at
developers.google.com/youtube.
I haven't looked into at all,
yet, so if anybody has any
more information on
what the YouTube
Data API v3 is, excellent.
I don't.
NICK BUTCHER: Cool.
Right.
So do anyone live in the room
have any questions?
Or should we jump right on
into that moderator?
TAL: I had a quick question
about something simple, but I
didn't find it.
[INAUDIBLE]
when a user presses on a button
on my app, I want to
lock the device, to send
it to Lock Screen.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: OK.
TAL: And didn't find exactly
how do I do it.
I heard something [? with ?]
administrative permissions or
something that.
I don't know.
MATT GAUNT: [INAUDIBLE]?
RICHARD HYNDMAN: No,
[INAUDIBLE].
Your [INAUDIBLE] than
mine, [INAUDIBLE].
TAL: So how do I go about it
to get the device to go to
Lock Screen, once, let's
say, [? he ?] presses a
button in my app?
RICHARD HYNDMAN: I assume
you've done the normal
searches on the Stack Overflow
and Google and stuff?
TAL: Yeah.
I tried a few sample codes that
people left, but none of
them seem to do the job.
HUGO: I think, in the
past, you could set
the writers to 0.
It would lock the [? phone. ?]
I'm not sure if that's
official or--
RICHARD HYNDMAN: No,
definitely not.
HUGO: --if it's working--
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Is this a
question from [? Tal, ?] by
any chance?
NICK BUTCHER: [INAUDIBLE].
NICK BUTCHER: If you get
the Keyguard service
and then invoke it.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: You can get
the KeyguardManager, but
people are saying for some
reason, it isn't working.
I don't know.
This is why we ask people to
please put their questions in
the moderator first.
Your app cannot stop anyone from
pressing the Home button.
[INAUDIBLE].
You can programmatically
lock the screen
with the Screen Locker.
KeyguardManager, system service
activity Keyguard service.
Have you tried that
one, [? Tal? ?]
TAL: No, I missed
that one on--
is it on Stack Overflow?
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Yeah.
It's the number one answer on
Stack Overflow when I searched
for lock Android device.
Look for the KeyguardManager
and the Disable Keyguard
Permission.
TAL: OK.
So I'll go and look at that, and
see where that leads me.
Is that the Nexus 10?
RICHARD HYNDMAN: The one that's
illuminating my face?
It's giving me a suntan.
TAL: [? Now-- ?]
yeah.
I got one [INAUDIBLE],
so it's pretty--
RICHARD HYNDMAN: The one that's
illuminating my face?
It's giving me a suntan.
TAL: [? Now-- ?]
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Somebody's
[INAUDIBLE]
be--
MATT GAUNT: I think
it's Marie.
TAL: And--
RICHARD HYNDMAN: [INAUDIBLE].
TAL: Is that the Nexus
10 over there?
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Yeah.
NICK BUTCHER: Are we
in a loop here?
No it looks like we do have
a [INAUDIBLE] new
faces here, as well.
We have Giuseppe, [INAUDIBLE]
Giuseppe.
And Marie.
I think-- is this the
first time you've
ever joined us, Marie?
No, it looks like we
do [INAUDIBLE]
faces here, as well.
We have Giuseppe, [INAUDIBLE]
Giuseppe.
And Marie.
I think-- is this the
first time you've
ever joined us, Marie?
MARIE: Yes.
NICK BUTCHER: [INAUDIBLE]
new faces here, as well.
We have Giuseppe, [INAUDIBLE].
RICHARD HYNDMAN: [INAUDIBLE],
as well as in Hangout.
NICK BUTCHER: Marie?
MARIE: Yes.
[INAUDIBLE]
NICK BUTCHER: Close
the YouTube tab.
MARIE: The sound is really
[INAUDIBLE].
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Yeah.
You're watching us twice
at the same time.
Bye.
[INAUDIBLE].
RICHARD HYNDMAN: So Marie is
on an infinite loop there,
unfortunately.
NICK BUTCHER: I think you
need to close the
YouTube tab, Marie.
And then, hopefully, it will
only come through once through
the Hangout.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Bye.
Wrong tab.
OK.
NICK BUTCHER: And who
else do we got?
We've got Andrew Kelly
down here?
Hello, [? Clemens. ?]
RICHARD HYNDMAN: There he is.
[INAUDIBLE].
MARIE: No.
Now.
OK.
It works.
No, it wasn't the YouTube.
It was a--
I have a special microphone.
[LAUGHTER]
MARIE: What's wrong with you?
[INAUDIBLE].
RICHARD HYNDMAN:
It's Christmas.
We're having--
GIUSEPPE: [INAUDIBLE].
MARIE: Hello, from Germany.
Hello, Nick.
GIUSEPPE: [INAUDIBLE]
Italy.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: OK.
MARIE: I want to tell you, have
a nice Christmas time.
And thank you for all
[INAUDIBLE]--
Yes, just--
I want to say just hello.
NICK BUTCHER: Hello.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: I wish I could
take the camera out and
show you around the office.
MARIE: --new message for you.
[INAUDIBLE]
my new hoodie, I have a
Android in my pocket.
[LAUGHTER]
HUGO: Aw.
NICK BUTCHER: I'm a medium,
Rich is a large, and--
MATT GAUNT: Medium, as well.
Yeah.
MARIE: How are you, Richard.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: I'm
doing very well.
Thank you, Marie.
MARIE: What are you
doing in holiday?
[LAUGHTER]
RICHARD HYNDMAN: I really meant
to finish my app up.
I know there's only
one screen left.
I'm close.
I'm just waiting for
your feedback.
I know.
It's getting very close now, but
I didn't get a chance to
work on it.
I was buying Christmas
presents and stuff.
And see the hat.
MARIE: OK.
NICK BUTCHER: Promise.
This Christmas, you're going to
finish your updates to the
ultimate [? clipboard. ?]
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Absolutely.
NICK BUTCHER: [INAUDIBLE]
the entire experience.
[? Everyone can ?] see just
how easy it is to have a
personal [INAUDIBLE].
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Epic.
NICK BUTCHER: Excellent.
MARIE: OK.
I have a question.
When do you plan to start in
2013, your Android Design In
Action show?
On the first January
week or second?
NICK BUTCHER: That's a good
question, actually.
I don't think we've
even decided yet.
What's the first Tuesday
in 2013?
MARIE: Oh, horrible.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Monday,
the 7th sounds good.
Yeah, Tuesday, the 8th.
NICK BUTCHER: Tuesday,
the 8th.
MARIE: Somebody tried to--
NICK BUTCHER: No rest.
MARIE: --to call me.
OK.
NICK BUTCHER: I don't know.
We'll speak to [? Adam and ?]
Roman, and we'll announce
something.
MARIE: That would be nice.
Maybe I can prepare something.
NICK BUTCHER: Oh, nice.
MARIE: [INAUDIBLE] big plans.
And I saw my office today, and
you're invited to join us in
Berlin next year for
a special plan.
And maybe, I see
you in January.
I got the [? mail ?] from
your colleague.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: OK.
All secrets to us but awesome
if that happens.
[LAUGHTER]
RICHARD HYNDMAN: We have enough
of your artwork up
around the office, now, to make
you very much at home.
We probably have more of you
artwork up in our office than
you have in your own house.
[LAUGHTER]
RICHARD HYNDMAN: [INAUDIBLE].
OK.
MARIE: I don't want to interrupt
your Developer
Office Hours.
I know, I'm a designer.
I have to leave.
[LAUGHTER]
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Yep.
Get out.
[LAUGHTER]
MARIE: [INAUDIBLE]
big discussion.
And yeah.
I just want to say, hello.
And have a nice Christmas
time, and see you soon.
NICK BUTCHER: Thank
you very much.
Same to you.
MATT GAUNT: Yeah.
Happy New Year, as well.
MARIE: Thank you for
all your work.
Bye.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Cheers.
OK, so [? Clemens ?] has asked
us a question in the chat
window, which Matt's going
to lean forward and read.
MATT GAUNT: [INAUDIBLE]
if this is relevant here because
it's a Google service.
NICK BUTCHER: Yep, it is.
MATT GAUNT: If you have time,
at some point, [INAUDIBLE]
actually.
OK.
So what [? Clemens' ?]
question, [INAUDIBLE]
has come through in the
G+ thread, and--
[MUSIC PLAYING]
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Oh.
Giuseppe, Giuseppe.
[INAUDIBLE].
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Let's
get the G+ question.
NICK BUTCHER: First,
[INAUDIBLE]
says, cool sweater, Rich.
Where could he get one?
RICHARD HYNDMAN: I got this
last year, unfortunately.
I used it one week last year,
and now it's back in service
for the week before Christmas
this year.
NICK BUTCHER: I don't think I
want to know, unfortunately.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: They
were never on sale.
You just have to get
one printed.
[WHISTLING]
NICK BUTCHER: And
next up, Alex.
I think you asked this
same question in
the moderator thread.
Al asks, can I share a secondary
screen between
multiple devices?
For example, if I will connect
two Nexus 4s using some
[INAUDIBLE]
tablet to the same TV--
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Whoa,
whoa, whoa.
Two Nexus 4s, one
adaptor, one TV.
NICK BUTCHER: --can I see the
same layout that can be
controlled from both Nexus 4s?
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Can
you have two--
NICK BUTCHER: So the
answer is no.
[LAUGHTER]
NICK BUTCHER: Basically, the way
that [INAUDIBLE] standard
works is it's a Wi-Fi direct
connection between one device
and the adaptor.
So I can't, to start with, see
any way that you could have
two devices connecting to the
adaptor at any one time.
And then, the way that the
presentation API works, the
second screen API on Android, is
it's very much one layout.
It's almost like a
dialog really.
Good [INAUDIBLE]
[? contacts ?]
and so on.
It's actually attached and
owned by one application
[? onto ?] the phone.
So it's not like you can even
background the application and
still have something
on the screen.
It's very much [? paired ?]
between what's on the screen
and what's on the device.
So you'd have to use some kind
of intermediary thing.
So maybe one device
could be a host.
And the other phone could
connect to the other phone.
So you probably could use
Wi-Fi direct [INAUDIBLE]
time.
Probably use some other socket
connection or Bluetooth or
something like that to talk
between the phones themselves.
And one of things would have to
be the master controlling
what's on the TV display.
That's the only way I could see
[INAUDIBLE] doing that.
Or you could perhaps use
something like GTV where GTV,
the Google TV itself could
be the master.
And then, both phones
talking to that.
MATT GAUNT: Yeah.
[INAUDIBLE] we [INAUDIBLE]
protocol, so that would be able
to handle the multiple
devices connect to the
one Google TV device.
And then, yeah.
Because it's got its own
application it can deal with
however you want to do it.
If you want to have
[INAUDIBLE]
priority of the other devices.
Yeah.
So, yeah.
There's a couple options
on the Google TV side.
NICK BUTCHER: So hopefully
there's a few options for you.
Thanks for the question, Alex.
And so has [? Clemens ?]
typed out his question now?
MATT GAUNT: Yes.
OK.
So what I missed in v3 is there
is actually no way, at
least documented
to [INAUDIBLE]
service is all-- is
available or not.
So I'm assuming this is checking
that the In-app
Billing version v3
is available?
[? RICHARD HYNDMAN: Or you ?]
can check that.
MATT GAUNT: Yeah.
I would've thought so.
I then implemented a little
method, which checks for the
com.android.vend
ing.billing.InAp
pBillingService.BIND
service intent.
But I don't actually know if
that will totally work.
So I'm asking myself why that
feature is missing.
Will it be [INAUDIBLE] some--
[INAUDIBLE].
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Not quite
sure what you mean,
[? Clemens. ?]
MATT GAUNT: So how would you
go about checking the v3
In-app Billing [INAUDIBLE]
the question.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: [INAUDIBLE]
is billing available?
MATT GAUNT: Yeah.
There is a Google--
yeah.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: There is a call
for is billing available,
which we'll check.
NICK BUTCHER: It's the first
thing all of [INAUDIBLE]
do, right?
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Yeah.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: But you
have to bind first.
You bind to the service,
and then you check--
You ask the service if
billing is available.
And if the bind to the service
fails, then assume the service
isn't there.
Maybe he wants to know if
there's a way of checking
whether the service is going
to be there before.
MATT GAUNT: But then, that would
be filtered out based on
the Play Store filtering,
wouldn't it?
RICHARD HYNDMAN: v3 is backwards
compatible though.
MATT GAUNT: I'll have
a double-look.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: All right.
NICK BUTCHER: OK.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: OK.
NICK BUTCHER: Another question
has come up in the G+ thread,
while [INAUDIBLE] digs
around for a link.
Dan Williams asks, he has
recently optimized his
application for tablet
devices.
How does Google Play determine
when an app is
optimized for tablets?
Ie.
How do I make it visible
to the tablet users?
So the answer is, your manifest,
basically, tells
Google Play which screens your
application supports.
And that's it really.
So you don't need to
do any extra steps.
It's not like some others stores
out there where you
have to opt in and tick a box
or something like that.
Your app, using the support
screen's manifest within your
application, tells Google Play
what devices can run it.
[INAUDIBLE] that's done.
But good job, yeah.
One thing you will hopefully
see is that we are doing
something where applications
which run better and optimized
for tablets will hopefully start
ranking better on tablet
devices when searching
in the Play store.
So hopefully you'll see that.
There's nothing you
have to do.
That's just us tweaking our
internal algorithms, which we
can't share the details of.
HUGO: Is the Play store now
looking at the smallest width
qualifier, or still at the
support screen [? stuff? ?]
NICK BUTCHER: The filtering,
yeah, is not using the
smallest width just yet.
It's still using
support screen.
But at some point in the future
hopefully we'll be
moving to that.
HUGO: OK.
NICK BUTCHER: Anything
to add [INAUDIBLE]?
MATT GAUNT: No.
Sounds really good to me.
NICK BUTCHER: OK.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Ah.
Refresh.
NICK BUTCHER: All right.
Should we take [INAUDIBLE]
any live questions in
the [? room? ?]
GIUSEPPE: Can I ask a [? good ?]
question, please?
NICK BUTCHER: [INAUDIBLE]
Giuseppe.
GIUSEPPE: Hello.
I was reading this morning news
about the new encryption
in Jelly Bean, OK?
About the APK, the application
encryption.
Can anyone suggest a good
documentation somewhere to
read and understand well how
to use this new feature in
Jelly Bean to encrypt the
APK to the [INAUDIBLE]?
RICHARD HYNDMAN: [INAUDIBLE]
for you by the Play store.
You don't have to do anything,
but it only affects 4.1
[? upwards. ?]
GIUSEPPE: [INAUDIBLE]?
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Yes.
It's automatic.
NICK BUTCHER: [INAUDIBLE].
GIUSEPPE: Only starting--
only starting Jelly Bean, or
in the future we can expect
some [INAUDIBLE]
for [INAUDIBLE]?
[TYPING]
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Only on Jelly
Bean [? upwards. ?]
GIUSEPPE: Only on Jelly Bean.
OK.
So this will be done
automatically.
Or in the future the old
application from [INAUDIBLE]
application will disappear,
right?
RICHARD HYNDMAN: [INAUDIBLE]
GIUSEPPE: Richard,
can you hear me?
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Yes, yes.
GIUSEPPE: So this means that
in the future, all the
application will be encrypted
automatically?
NICK BUTCHER: Paid
applications.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Paid
GIUSEPPE: OK.
[INAUDIBLE].
RICHARD HYNDMAN: As all people
upgrade to Jelly Bean, onward.
Yeah.
NICK BUTCHER: [INAUDIBLE]
there is nothing
for you to do.
If you're interested
in [? hard work, ?]
I did read an interesting tear
down, I guess, of looking at
how the service works
under the hood.
Which is on Nikolay
Elenkov's blog.
If you go to
nelenkov.blogspot.com, there's
an interesting assessment of
the service just for your
background.
But as a developer, there's
nothing for you to do.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: OK.
NICK BUTCHER: Any other
questions from people in the
Hangout before we jump into the
pre-submitted questions?
HUGO: Yeah.
I might have one.
I've been trying to [? port ?]
over Rainy Days to the new
Maps API, but the biggest
trouble is animating a layer.
In the previous API, I could
just [INAUDIBLE] something.
But now it's all [INAUDIBLE]
overlays or whatever, there
seems to be no good way to
animate, besides switching the
layers, of course.
So I don't expect really
an answer, but--
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Animate what?
Sorry.
From point to point or
animate [INAUDIBLE]?
NICK BUTCHER: The marker.
HUGO: No, I have [INAUDIBLE]
my application shows a rain
radar image, so it steps
through the time
from like 10 minutes--
in steps of 10 minutes.
So that layer, itself,
is animated and
projected on the map.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: OK.
HUGO: But in--
so in [INAUDIBLE]
I just have an overlay that I
animate myself using a handler
and those kinds of things.
But in the new API, you have
to actually add some
[INAUDIBLE] overlay or
[INAUDIBLE] sets or those
kinds of things.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: There's no
way of animating that?
HUGO: There is really
no good way.
If I try to set [? it ?] visible
or height one layer
and then, make another layer
visible, then it's not really
smooth or--
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Interesting.
No, I have not tried that--
animating a layer.
HUGO: I thought about just
drawing over it with a
[? view ?] or something, but I
guess that won't work either.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: No, I'm sure
a number of solutions will
emerge over the next couple of
months, if it is an issue.
But I haven't seen
it myself yet.
HUGO: OK.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
If you do that, can you put it
in a frame layer, and just
draw it-- your own layer
on top of the map?
HUGO: Yeah.
I thought about it, but then
I would also need a custom
location overlay for that.
NICK BUTCHER: You have to listen
to the panning events
and so forth.
Yeah.
HUGO: Yeah.
And for now--
for example, now I have an
option to show the location on
top of the clouds, so if it's
very cloudy, then you can see
your location still.
But, yeah.
If I go that route, then I have
to draw, basically, every
map thing, like location
[INAUDIBLE].
NICK BUTCHER: [INAUDIBLE]
Yeah.
Got it.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Interesting.
I have not tried that.
HUGO: But other than that,
no other questions.
NICK BUTCHER: So what's the
question from [INAUDIBLE]?
MATT GAUNT: So what's the
complete [INAUDIBLE]
backed by CursorLoader?
NICK BUTCHER: I think you
might be muted there,
[INAUDIBLE].
Do you want to unmute,
and then ask
the question yourself?
MALE SPEAKER: Hello.
NICK BUTCHER: Hi.
MALE SPEAKER: Hi,
how's it going?
I posted a question last weekend
or last Hangout.
And I wasn't able to join
because I guess
that group was full.
What I'm trying to accomplish
is, basically, have a
multi-autocomplete view backed
by a CursorLoader, but what I
want to have happen is have
a custom tokenizer.
So instead of having a common
delimited tokenizer, I wanted
to achieve something like a
space delimited tokenizer.
So I know I have to
override the--
I think it's in the
TextWatcher class.
TextWatcher [? has ?] an
onTextChanged method.
And I'm running into issues
as far so overriding that
because, for example, let's
say I type in the word Joe
Johnson or the two words, Joe
Johnson, I think the call to
onTextChanged happens more times
than I'm anticipating
when, basically, a delimiter
was entered like a space, I
expected it to only be called
once, but it's being called
like more than once.
NICK BUTCHER: OK.
MALE SPEAKER: So I'm not
able to successfully
implement this custom--
what's it called?
Like a custom TextWatcher.
But if I go take the approach
of using a simple
CursorAdaptor, and don't go
the CursorLoader approach,
then I'm able to implement it.
But it's not--
I don't think it's
as efficient.
NICK BUTCHER: So at what
stage are you trying--
how come you can do it with
the CursorAdaptor, but not
with the Loader?
MALE SPEAKER: I think it has
something to do with when I
did go with a simple
CursorAdaptor approach, then I
took a look at--
I have a filtered query provider
that has a run query
method that I'm overriding.
And I'm also noticing that
onTextChanged method, this run
query seems to be getting
called twice, as well.
So I'm not really familiar with
how the TextWatcher run
query method gets called.
I was expecting it to
just be called once.
When text it changed, I thought
it would just get
called once, but it seems
like it's getting
called more than once.
And there's an argument
in the onTextChanged
method, called [? s ?]
CharSequence.
It's a type CharSequence.
And that's, basically, the
length of the string.
So the first time onTextChanged
is called, it's
of a certain length.
And the second time
it's called, it's
of a different length.
So if I'm trying to do any kind
of processing of a custom
tokenizer, it's not what
I anticipated.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: [INAUDIBLE]
isn't the beforeTextChanged
[INAUDIBLE] and the one
afterwards is the
onTextChanged.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
So I tried to put some kind of
logic to see what the string
was before TextChanged and
after TextChanged.
I wasn't able to get something
to really work, as far as the
changing from the first call
to the second call.
So I was looking into that
approach, but I haven't come
up with any clean solutions.
MATT GAUNT: You're not--
you're not setting the text
at any point in these
methods, are you?
Like, if you're running it
through a tokenizer, then
stripping out spaces or white
characters and then--
MALE SPEAKER: Well, basically,
what I wanted to do is, as
soon as I saw delimiter, I
saved this value of s.
And then, I do something
with that value of s.
But the problem is this
onTextChanged gets called
twice, once--
instead of just being called
once after you see a
delimiter, it gets
called twice.
So the first time I see the
delimiter, it says, oh, the
string is Joe Johnson.
Then, the second time it
sees actually more
text, if I keep typing.
And instead of being that new
word, it has the entire string
of Joe Johnson plus
the extra text.
NICK BUTCHER: I think that's the
expected behavior, right?
The TextWatcher will
always return the
entire text of the--
in the editable text.
MALE SPEAKER: So is there any
way to get, as soon as you see
a delimiter, then grab
that first--
the text before the first
delimiter, and then,
basically, only see--
delimit it by potential
delimiters?
The thing that's tricky is that
the delimiter is a space
that I wouldn't use, but there
could be spaces within a text.
Basically, the text could be
like contacts, where you have
a first name and a last name
separated by a space.
But if this multi-autocomplete
text view has different
contacts, it could
have a bunch of
different contact names.
And within those contact names,
it has a first name and
a last name that happens
to have a space.
So that's where it becomes a
little tricky with just a
common delimiter.
NICK BUTCHER: It sounds like
you're going to have to keep
track of it yourself really.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
RICHARD HYNDMAN: --and decide
when you want to keep the
string, and when you don't
want to keep it.
NICK BUTCHER: I think
[INAUDIBLE]
it sounds like, at some point,
you're putting set text within
your TextWatcher, which is
entirely legitimate.
You can do that, but you need
to handle the case so you
don't end up in some kind of
recursive loop or anything.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
MATT GAUNT: --I had was if you
had a [INAUDIBLE] where you
could only enter in valid
information, which then
affected other [INAUDIBLE].
Then it reinfected that one.
If you start getting really kind
of messy traps, you have
to make sure you get to a point
where you account for
that, basically.
NICK BUTCHER: And the other
thing you could take a look at
is the Chips UI, which is
the UI we use in the SMS
application on Android.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
NICK BUTCHER: Similarly,
[INAUDIBLE]
which is open source so you
can take [INAUDIBLE]
Chips UI, I think it's clled,
which gives you those-- you
know, as you enter a name,
it turns it into a little
[INAUDIBLE].
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
I was reading a little bit about
that, but I didn't get
to check out the documentation
yet.
MATT GAUNT: I think there's
[INAUDIBLE]
somewhere isn't there?
NICK BUTCHER: I'm not sure.
MATT GAUNT: I've seen
it come up a
couple of times somewhere.
But, yeah.
[INAUDIBLE]
MALE SPEAKER: I was
thinking, maybe
potentially, my approach--
once I see a delimited--
like let's say someone
typed in Joe Johnson.
And then, they pressed Space.
Then I can save this in
some global variable.
And regardless of what the
onTextChanged is, then I just
update that global variable.
And I can put some arbitrary
delimiter within this string,
so I could say Joe Johnson.
And then, put like
a [? pipe ?]
that would just delimit it
in this arbitrary string.
And then, if more text is added,
onTextChanged will
always show what's in the Edit
Text View, but my global
string will show how
it's delimited.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
That sounds reasonable.
Either like holding them
in a map or a set or
something like that.
Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: Something.
Like that.
OK.
And I'll take a look at that
Chips UI or the Chips--
in the Messenger.
NICK BUTCHER: [INAUDIBLE].
MALE SPEAKER: Thank you.
NICK BUTCHER: No worries.
Good luck.
But just go back to
your question.
Why were you trying to
[INAUDIBLE], rather than using
the OnQuery?
MALE SPEAKER: Because I wanted
to, basically, asynchronously
do the loading in
the background.
And I've read that CursorLoaders
are a lot more
efficient at that.
Instead of blocking the main
UI, I thought it would be a
better approach.
MATT GAUNT: Does a lot of the
heavy lifting, isn't it?
NICK BUTCHER: Well, I think most
[INAUDIBLE] will do that,
anyway, for you, right?
You normally use a--
what's it called--
it's an async query
anyway, isn't it?
[INAUDIBLE].
I forget what it's called.
Yeah.
I think it normally does it
asynchronously anyway.
So I wouldn't--
MALE SPEAKER: Oh.
A multi--
oh.
It already does it
asynchronously?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
So potentially, just using a
simple CursorAdaptor, it's as
efficient as it needs to be.
Because with the simple
CursorAdaptor, I think, what
happened is something about I
needed to manage the Cursor.
And it wasn't closed properly.
That's why it went with
the CursorLoader,
so it handled that--
[INAUDIBLE]
Cursor and managing
that efficiently.
I think I turned on
a debugging mode--
one of the strict modes-- and
it complained because the
Cursor wasn't closed
correctly.
So that's why I went with the
approach of CursorLoader that
would manage that Cursor.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
The standard use case is using
AsyncQueryHandler with
[INAUDIBLE], right?
Is that what you're doing?
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
So AsyncQueryHandler
[INAUDIBLE]
UI.
So, yeah.
You're OK there.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
And then, I just have
to figure out where
to close that Cursor.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
You have to manage
that yourself.
Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
All right.
Thank you.
NICK BUTCHER: No worries.
Cool.
OK.
We've got some chat going
on in the sidebar.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: It's just
about Hugo's maps.
NICK BUTCHER: Oh, OK.
About the animated Maps
question still.
[INAUDIBLE].
Any more live questions from
the people in the room?
I see we were just joined
by a couple of people.
We've got AJ I think.
How are you doing?
And some usual suspects,
as well.
No last questions?
You guys [INAUDIBLE] questions
[INAUDIBLE]?
RICHARD HYNDMAN: [INAUDIBLE]
from the Netherlands, almost
certainly, [INAUDIBLE].
NICK BUTCHER: I bet.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: It's asking--
NICK BUTCHER: That
could be anyone.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Because
that can be anyone.
It does start with, will
it ever be possible.
But it's not really a question
we should be
answering in this forum.
Will it ever be possible to
remotely debug an Android
application, running
on a device without
connecting a cable?
[INAUDIBLE].
Obviously, Google TV devices
already allow this, but
Android devices, in
general, don't.
There's a few ways, if
you've got a rooted
device, you can do it.
[INAUDIBLE]
ADB [INAUDIBLE]
instead.
It connects through
wirelessly.
I've seen people doing
this, but I've not
heard anything about--
no future announcements, et
cetera, et cetera, et cetera.
HUGO: Yeah.
I think you can put it in TCP
mode, right, when you have
[INAUDIBLE]
your phone connected through
USB [? once, ?]
then you can [INAUDIBLE].
Let me look up the command.
But it's something like ADB TCP
or something like this.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Yeah.
HUGO: And then, you can connect
to it the same way as
you connect to Google TV.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: There's no UI
for getting the IP address
back out of it again.
HUGO: Well, you can look at
the wireless setting, like
you're doing with Google TV.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: [INAUDIBLE].
MATT GAUNT: So the way the
Google TV side of it works, is
you have enter in the IP address
in the machine you're
going to connect to.
And then, from your machine,
ADB connect with the IP
address of the device.
And then, from that point,
you create a
two-way pairing process.
And then, you're good to go.
And then, it just looks like
a USB device, essentially.
But, yeah.
In Germany, I think most
developers are happy
connecting cables [INAUDIBLE].
HUGO: Yeah.
And the thing is that you have
to first put it in TCP mode
with the cables [INAUDIBLE].
If you're able to do that, then
you probably just want to
stick the cable [? in it. ?]
MATT GAUNT: Yeah, exactly.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Well, I'm still
pretty sure it's only
available if you're on
rooted device, right?
MATT GAUNT: Yeah.
I think I remember seeing
it at some point.
[INAUDIBLE]
or something, but yeah.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: I think you
can only set your device in
TCP mode if you are rooted.
HUGO: Really?
RICHARD HYNDMAN: I'm
just trying to find
it myself now, but--
HUGO: It's a question
on Stack Overflow.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Does someone
on Stack Overflow got an
answer, which doesn't
require root?
HUGO: Yes.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Do you know
what the question number is?
MATT GAUNT: He just pasted it.
HUGO: I just pasted it.
It's a long number.
NICK BUTCHER: Cool.
In the G+ comments,
Carlos asks--
has a question about moderators
in Android dev community.
Can you--
I'm going to ask Carlos, can you
give us some more details
about what you think.
There's not enough moderation
going on in
the Android dev community?
Or are you enjoying it
or what's going on?
Yeah, some more details,
please.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: That answer
there does say if your device
is rooted, Hugo, at the top.
HUGO: Yeah, but the
second paragraph.
From a computer, if
you [INAUDIBLE]
USB access already, that
part just works.
I'm pretty sure I did that.
MATT GAUNT: [INAUDIBLE].
HUGO: Because I borrowed some
phones from a colleague.
And then, I gave him back his
phone, but [INAUDIBLE].
NICK BUTCHER: Cool.
HUGO: I can try it right now.
NICK BUTCHER: [INAUDIBLE]
Jamie [INAUDIBLE]
says, I need to share a class
worth from Android screens
with the teacher.
Can someone point me
in right direction?
I can access the output on a PC
with USB, but I need this
over wireless, so a teacher can
view what is going on in
their class.
So I guess you're trying to
[INAUDIBLE] some kind of
wireless screen chat, so I'm
going to say that the
[INAUDIBLE], which is
probably [INAUDIBLE]
you're going to need to have a
Nexus 4 [INAUDIBLE] dongle of
which I don't know of any
on the market just yet.
Any other solutions
you could use?
RICHARD HYNDMAN: There's loads
of HDMI broadcasters.
If you've got HDMI, [INAUDIBLE]
get a little box
to use wireless HDMI to HDMI.
VNC, isn't that on Android
somewhere?
Maybe it only goes one way.
You can view the desktop
from the tablet,
but not vice versa?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
MATT GAUNT: [INAUDIBLE]
Droid, can you do [INAUDIBLE]
NICK BUTCHER: Can you do
screen share on an app?
There's Droid [INAUDIBLE] screen
or something like that.
[INAUDIBLE] you've already
managed to get it
onto a PC over USB.
And then, could you share from
the PC to your teacher
somehow, perhaps?
RICHARD HYNDMAN: But, yeah.
The ideal way would be--
MATT GAUNT: And I think this is
to make sure that all the
kids are doing what they're
told, maybe.
Because it sounds like
each kid has got
their own Android device.
And then, the teacher is
supposed to make sure what
they're doing is right.
[INAUDIBLE].
[BANGING]
RICHARD HYNDMAN: [INAUDIBLE]
Android [INAUDIBLE].
MATT GAUNT: So it's kind
of like [INAUDIBLE]
style, where you get all the
devices coming [INAUDIBLE]
screen shots.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Yeah.
You need something custom
[? firmware ?]
[INAUDIBLE] that property,
really.
MATT GAUNT: Yeah.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: And the teacher
would be able to
choose which one of the screens
she was looking at.
And what was going on on that
screen and all that is
definitely against our
security model.
NICK BUTCHER: An interesting
one there.
[INAUDIBLE]
interesting question from
Gabriel [INAUDIBLE].
He asks--
he has a [INAUDIBLE]
and with multiple pages, with
multiple list views
in each of the pages.
At the moment, each list
fragment is querying different
parts of the same
database table.
At the moment, each fragment
queries the--
has the same [INAUDIBLE]
querying the database.
And he's wondering if it would
be more efficient to have one
query [? against ?]
that table and at the
activity level.
And then, [? farm ?] out
that information to
the different fragments.
[INAUDIBLE].
MATT GAUNT: Well, databases are
inherently secured against
asynchronous queries,
aren't they?
What about Cursors?
Because if they're not, then I
could imagine you could get
into some sticky situations.
Where if you're flipping between
the two, and both
adaptors are fed set off
of the same Cursor,
then it could lock.
So it might actually be safer to
do it the way you're doing
it because then you'd have
independent Cursors, so--
RICHARD HYNDMAN: We need
a bit more information.
It depends how much data
we're talk about here.
If he's talking about like
5, 10k of data, whatever.
Then, yeah, fair enough.
Maybe load that into the
activity and just use it
inside the application.
If you can load it without the
application suffering,
[INAUDIBLE]
being concerned about memory.
But if he's talking about much
more data, then potentially
you could load the first level
of all the data for all the l
And then when you drill down,
load that separately.
MATT GAUNT: Well, if you've got
a view pager and you're
recycling the list fragments
as you're swiping, then you
could load all the data you need
for that one fragment.
Then, as it gets wiped off and
killed, you'd kill the data--
NICK BUTCHER: But the
view pager wouldn't
recycle right, see?
[INAUDIBLE].
MATT GAUNT: There is a version
where you can make it
do it, can't you?
No?
[INAUDIBLE].
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Yeah.
It sounds like, depending on how
you've got your view pager
set up and the amount of data,
that it may be a good idea.
But we just need a little
bit more information--
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: --else
in the string.
NICK BUTCHER: My worry is the
whole point of using Cursors.
It can be like an arbitrary
list [INAUDIBLE]
grow into an [? arbitrarily ?]
large data set.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: So what?
NICK BUTCHER: [? --and I ?]
worry about [INAUDIBLE]
to manage them all yourself and
piece them back together.
And you're returning a much
larger data set in it.
I think the idea-- you know, I
don't know if there's a right
answer here.
I think you could probably end
up writing a lot more code.
It might be a little bit more
efficient, but then, the
overhead of having to do
it all yourself might
not be worth it.
So you could do a test, and
see if it works out.
Any good advice?
MATT GAUNT: Yeah.
For me, it's just a little
bit more information.
But, yeah.
I kind of agree.
If you're managing all of that
yourself, there's a lot of
room where I think things could
start just leaking and
lead to some bad times.
NICK BUTCHER: I think Carlos
has replied to
his original question.
MATT GAUNT: Oh, yeah.
OK.
Carlos says, the main problem
with the Android dev
community, he's saying, is
there's quite a lot of
advertising [INAUDIBLE]
different levels of
questions and so on.
Maybe different sections or
different levels of Q&A
[INAUDIBLE]
Android.
So we have different sub-forums
in there, right?
What are they?
I don't remember
[? off-hand. ?]
[INAUDIBLE]?
RICHARD HYNDMAN: What
was the question?
Sub-forums, is this
Carlos' question?
MATT GAUNT: On the Android
community.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: [INAUDIBLE]?
MATT GAUNT: Yeah.
So there are sub-sections,
right?
[INAUDIBLE].
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
There are sub-sections
on there.
If you think that we need some
more, then we'd be happy to
add some more, [? if ?]
needs be.
At the moment, I think
the communities are
all settling down.
I think there's a bit of a
communities rush at the moment
where everyone trying to get
everyone to join each other's
communities-- a lot of
cross-pollination.
I think we've had quite
a light hand.
We've tried not to moderate
too hard.
And only things which are
completely off-topic--
if there's some overlaps,
someone saying, you know, join
our design and developers
community or something like
that, which is [? valued ?] to
some people, we've been trying
not to remove those
kind of posts.
But it sounds like you feel
that we could do some more
moderation.
So that's good feedback.
So does anyone else
in the Hangout
here have any feedback?
Have you been using the Android
Developer Community?
Have you found it useful?
Have you found It too noisy?
Has anyone else got any
experience they want to share?
No?
No one?
HUGO: [INAUDIBLE]
community?
NICK BUTCHER: The
G+ Community.
HUGO: There's a lot of
noise form people, I
want to make an app.
Where do I start?
NICK BUTCHER: I want to
make a what-- sorry?
RICHARD HYNDMAN: An app,
where do I start?
HUGO: There are a lot
of questions like, I
want to make an app.
Where do I start?
And then, yeah.
I point them to Android.com,
but that seems so
obvious to me that--
NICK BUTCHER: You think
we could do
like a newbies section?
Or a different community
almost?
HUGO: Yeah.
Something like that.
Just, maybe, if you have some
place to put frequently asked
questions or starting
points of--
because most of the responses
on those kinds of questions
are pointing to
[? developers.com/android ?]
[INAUDIBLE] developers
[INAUDIBLE]
training, right?
NICK BUTCHER: Right.
HUGO: That's the right place
to start, I guess.
There are a lot of those
kinds of questions.
Also, a lot of questions
that don't make
sense, in whatever way.
NICK BUTCHER: I think part of
the problem is it's quite a
large topic, isn't it,
Android development?
I mean, that--
HUGO: Yeah.
NICK BUTCHER: --Android
[INAUDIBLE] huge range from
newbie questions to incredibly
advanced questions.
I feel like the level of
discourse in the Android
Design Community has been less
noisy, I think, because it's a
smaller focus.
It's a smaller subset,
[INAUDIBLE].
HUGO: Yeah.
NICK BUTCHER: And maybe
that's what's missing.
I mean, we have the
sub-forums.
But you obviously get--
if you're in the community, you
see all of the things that
I'm talking about.
So it can feel noisier.
Perhaps we need to have other
communities or something.
I don't know.
That's some feedback we need to
take back and work out the
best way forward.
HUGO: But splitting out
the check out my
app was a good thing.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
I really like that idea of
being able to broadcast
potentially what you're
working on.
And letting other people know,
oh, this is what I've
worked on so far.
Check it out.
Maybe give some feedback.
MATT GAUNT: Pretty cool
for sort of early
testing, beta testers--
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
MATT GAUNT: --to get it to
community and get feedback.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: I feel like it's
kind of difficult to really
categorize where posts
can land because you
never really know--
there could be a really advanced
user posting on the
community, and then, some
novice developer.
So it's hard to just say, oh,
post directly to this
sub-community because there
will be overlap.
MATT GAUNT: Yeah, but I
guess you're always
going to have that.
There always needs to
be that entry point.
And then, people are going
to be pointed off
to the right thing.
And there will be people that
will just find the new--
if there was a new sort of
community, people would just
jump straight in there if it's
the first one they find, post
[INAUDIBLE]
probably better off asking that
in the main community.
So--
MALE SPEAKER: I think if there
was, maybe, the first time you
actually join the community,
I think it may be like
intimidating for some new person
to go and see, oh, this
is where I enter any type
of discussion--
if maybe the very first time
you join the community, it
says, if you are sort of a
novice user, we suggest going
and posting in this sub-forum.
MATT GAUNT: Yeah.
It's always been like--
you see it in the IRC channels
back in the day when Android
was fairly new, you kind of have
Google engineers versus
other people.
Yeah.
You'd have people come in.
And they'd literally just
ask product questions.
And then, it's like, go here.
So, yeah.
I guess you need that level of
direction one way [INAUDIBLE].
Yeah.
Good feedback.
NICK BUTCHER: Andrew in the
sidebar is commenting, it's
very noisy.
lots lof look at my
app posts too.
Rather than every community post
appearing in my timeline,
I would, maybe, only like
to see those from
people in my circles.
In order to view all posts,
I need to visit
the community page.
So kind of like the volume
sliders you can have on
circles, right?
RICHARD HYNDMAN: I don't get
community posts in my timeline.
MATT GAUNT: I get them.
But they're kind of
gently snuck in.
[INAUDIBLE]
MATT GAUNT: [INAUDIBLE]
the option, though, of only
getting them from [INAUDIBLE].
RICHARD HYNDMAN: [INAUDIBLE]
just says 99 plus
new messages.
[INAUDIBLE]
then, they have these little
things 99 plus [INAUDIBLE].
NICK BUTCHER: I get
[INAUDIBLE].
[INAUDIBLE]
and Carlos is suggesting that
maybe we could have some
helpers with a moderator
badge.
[INAUDIBLE]
communities.
Yeah.
I guess it kind of takes
on a bit of a forum
moderator style approach.
Yeah.
[INAUDIBLE] just haven't
noticed.
They're so relevant.
MATT GAUNT: Does anyone else
have any questions
[INAUDIBLE]?
NICK BUTCHER: I'm [? taking ?]
typing.
So we're just following a link
[INAUDIBLE], a lot of question
MATT GAUNT: --which I'm
instantly regretting, which
which I can't see.
NICK BUTCHER: [? Lock ?] screen
orientation of a Dream service.
So Michael has been fiddling
with the Dream service API.
Michael was in the
Hangout, right?
Can you ask the question
live [INAUDIBLE]?
[BANGING]
RICHARD HYNDMAN: What's the
first tab at the top?
NICK BUTCHER: No.
MATT GAUNT: Sorry.
NICK BUTCHER: Matt broke it.
MATT GAUNT: My bad.
I shant ever do that again.
[BANGING]
RICHARD HYNDMAN: I'm just
watching the live stream
[INAUDIBLE].
MATT GAUNT: [INAUDIBLE] we
had it freeze again.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: [INAUDIBLE].
I think we're still live.
Yeah.
We're still live, dude.
People are still watching us.
We're in a window somehow.
MATT GAUNT: Hello.
We thought we completely
left the Hangout.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: I just opened
the live stream and realized I
could still see myself.
So, there must have been a
window open somewhere.
Let's not click through
to links [INAUDIBLE].
MATT GAUNT: Yeah.
Not going to do that again.
If you have a question, you
have to type it out.
Otherwise, [INAUDIBLE].
RICHARD HYNDMAN: So is Michael
in the Hangout with us, there,
on the right-hand side?
NICK BUTCHER: [INAUDIBLE].
Michael, do you have a
camera or microphone?
I'm guessing not.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: I'm guessing
he's going to say no,
mic is messed up.
Sorry.
NICK BUTCHER: OK.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: In
this day and age?
Excellent.
MATT GAUNT: Should we go for
another moderator question?
Are there any more moderator
questions?
MATT GAUNT: [INAUDIBLE] got the
actual Stack Overflow in
the moderator.
I think we've done a few.
NICK BUTCHER: OK.
So we'll worry about Michael's
question from Stack Overflow.
So he's been playing with
the Dream service API.
And would like to lock the
screen orientation to a
landscape when the Dream service
is shown because he's
showing widescreen photos
and doesn't want
to have black bars.
He's tried a number of things
like Set Orientation and using
Android Screen Orientation
Landscape in the manifest, but
none have worked.
Which makes me wonder, is
it possible to lock the
orientation of a
Dream service?
Have you guys tried this?
MATT GAUNT: Can't say I have.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Not since
the API went public.
[? Previously. ?]
NICK BUTCHER: So, yeah.
That's the difference.
Dream service isn't
quite an activity.
It's similar to an activity, but
not actually an activity.
I'm wondering if you can get the
window manager and ask the
window managers to do
some stuff for you.
MATT GAUNT: That might be quite
a good way of doing it.
NICK BUTCHER: There's an
unattached window.
So the answer is, we don't
know off-hand.
I'm just thinking out loud.
MATT GAUNT: I mean, that would
make sense, though,
[INAUDIBLE]
there is a window feature,
[? wouldn't ?] you?
RICHARD HYNDMAN: All of the
current ones rely on landscape
or portrait, right?
NICK BUTCHER: I see in the
comments, Andrew Kelly
suggesting you could use a
different crop type-- scale
type-- in your image views so
you don't have the black bars.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Yeah.
I think the better solution
would be to make it support
portrait, to be honest, instead
of just landscape.
People may want to have
it either way around.
And all the current Dreams
do support both.
I'm just making sure that the
current Dream supports both.
Yeah.
MATT GAUNT: I mean, that might
be the option, as well, is
have multiple images, rather
than just the one.
I do believe I tried to mess
with the window manager.
Yeah.
[INAUDIBLE]
but the result has only showing
40% of the image
[INAUDIBLE]
scale type.
So maybe try doing something
nice with multiple images and
[? animating ?]
around when you change--
RICHARD HYNDMAN: But really,
please just try and support
both orientations.
I mean, [? my dock ?] for Nexus
4 would be portrait.
And for my Nexus 7 or 10
would be landscape.
And if I wanted to use your
Dream on both, one of them
wouldn't be available.
So it'd be nice if you
just supported both.
Let the user choose which way
around they want their device.
MATT GAUNT: Andrew Kelly is
suggesting Ken Burns effect.
I like it.
Thinking outside the box.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: OK.
Is there anything in the
moderator that you can see.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
So Andrew asks, [INAUDIBLE]
In-app Billing doesn't support
subscriptions.
Are you working on it?
We're not going to announce
anything, but that sounds like
a safe assumption.
[LAUGHING]
NICK BUTCHER: Again, from Andrew
Kelly, the one-man
moderating machine, you asked,
in response [INAUDIBLE]
piracy question last week,
wasn't it mentioned at Google
I/O that future [INAUDIBLE]
a device.
Say that's correct.
That's the app encryption that
we talked about earlier with
Giuseppe's question.
[INAUDIBLE] the Dream
Service question.
Jamie asks, is there a way to
work out the measured height
and width of a text
view [INAUDIBLE]
before it's drawn?
I've tried getting the image
height working [INAUDIBLE].
And then, the length
and height of
the text using Paint.
It's close, but it's
still a bit off.
If I was going to interpret the
question correctly, you're
trying to get the measured
height of a view.
But it sounds like you're trying
to get it before it's
actually been measured.
So the correct approach, I would
say, rather than trying
to imitate what the layout
system is doing, is wait until
it's actually been measured.
And then, get it.
So if you look at something
called the View Tree Observer
[? class, ?]
you can get a View
Tree Observer for
your current activity.
And attach [INAUDIBLE]
global layout.
I think that's the name
of the event.
So you can get a callback once
it's done the laying out and
measuring [? parse ?]
of your application?
So at that point, once the
measuring is completed, you
can then query your view to get
the pixel size, once it's
been measured.
So I'd say, do that, rather
than trying to imitate the
layout system.
MATT GAUNT: Good call.
NICK BUTCHER: Done that one.
Done that one.
Cool.
Andrew Kelly asks, when creating
entries in the
device's [INAUDIBLE]
done directly, rather than
[INAUDIBLE], is there a way to
include HTML links or
image attachments?
Do [? you got the answer? ?]
RICHARD HYNDMAN: I don't.
I haven't [? gotten to the ?]
extras you can [? put. ?]
NICK BUTCHER: And so my gut
feeling is, I think that you
only have access to the notes
field, in which case, you can
put any text, but I don't
think you can actually
[? mark ?] it up in any way.
I don't believe.
What happens if you put
a link in there.
I haven't tried it.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: I see
Andrew has tried it.
He's typing now.
And [INAUDIBLE] not marked up.
Any markup I supplied just
gets rendered as text.
Fair enough.
[INAUDIBLE]
layout URLs.
MATT GAUNT: Aw, sad face.
NICK BUTCHER: And I'm not
trying [INAUDIBLE].
MATT GAUNT: If you're getting
access to the content provider
to put the entries into the
calendar stuff, if you could
get access to another calendar
entry in the content provider,
then maybe you could find out
what the official one does.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
Create an event through the
web URLs [INAUDIBLE]
put a link in it.
And see how it gets saved.
Could be interesting.
MATT GAUNT: That's, obviously,
depending whether you can get
access to it from the
Android side or not.
NICK BUTCHER: Should
be able to.
MATT GAUNT: Yeah.
In which case, do that.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
[INAUDIBLE]
or look at the source code.
MATT GAUNT: Yeah.
There you go.
Because then, you should
be able to see what the
[INAUDIBLE]
[? does, as ?] well.
Yeah.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Check
the source.
I'd like to create a link to
re-launch an app when clicked
from a calendar entry.
Fair enough.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
I think you can do that.
I think that's what [INAUDIBLE]
did, right, when
they re-did it?
MATT GAUNT: Well, I guess that's
getting it to launch an
app from a URL.
You could do it [INAUDIBLE].
NICK BUTCHER: [INAUDIBLE]
filter.
MATT GAUNT: Yeah.
NICK BUTCHER: Carlos in Madrid
says, are we going to see a
better API for official
functionality for gaming apps.
That then, falls into the
not commenting on future
[INAUDIBLE] announcements.
So, sorry.
[INAUDIBLE].
RICHARD HYNDMAN: [INAUDIBLE].
NICK BUTCHER: Oh.
That's [INAUDIBLE], you
did read ahead.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Ah.
Yes.
You didn't think I picked
him out of [INAUDIBLE]
country, city.
Is France a country?
NICK BUTCHER: And seeing as
we're running out of time,
we'll give the people live in
the Hangout a last, final
chance to ask any questions
[INAUDIBLE].
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Final
chance this year.
NICK BUTCHER: --ask or add or
say goodbye or anything?
TAL: I've got [INAUDIBLE].
NICK BUTCHER: Go ahead,
[? Tal. ?]
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
I had a question about how
to set up the [INAUDIBLE]
display on a Nexus 4.
Is there a certain app that
you need to download?
Or is it just you need an
adaptor on a TV, and it
automatically sticks?
NICK BUTCHER: It's under the
Display setting, right?
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Yeah.
Under Display, you just turn
Wi-Fi displays on, and then it
appears in your Quick Settings
menu, the two finger drag down
[INAUDIBLE]-- it's actually the
one finger [INAUDIBLE].
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
So if you go to Displays on
your Settings app, there's
[INAUDIBLE] options
[? as what ?] is displayed.
MALE SPEAKER: Oh, OK.
NICK BUTCHER: And once it's
on, then you should get an
option in the Quick
Settings menu.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: And
you can tap it.
And it'll tell you if there's
displays detected.
And if there are, you
just connect.
And you're off.
MALE SPEAKER: Thanks.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Good to go.
[INAUDIBLE].
NICK BUTCHER: [INAUDIBLE]
display.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: [INAUDIBLE]
Nice.
And I can't wait to get myself
a dongle and try it out.
Hopefully we'll have
a lot more on the
market in Q1 next year.
NICK BUTCHER: [INAUDIBLE].
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Different
companies.
Yeah.
[INAUDIBLE].
MALE SPEAKER: I have a laptop
that has [INAUDIBLE]
capabilities, but I'm not able
to detect the laptop, as far
as a wireless display.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: No.
OK.
[INAUDIBLE] and [INAUDIBLE]
two different, most likely,
different standards, at least.
MALE SPEAKER: Oh.
It's a little bit different?
RICHARD HYNDMAN: They're
probably both transmitting
devices, not receiving
devices.
MALE SPEAKER: Oh, OK.
Yeah.
So the laptop is not
a receiving device?
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Right.
You can't just broadcast--
MALE SPEAKER: Got it.
NICK BUTCHER:
[? Same reason you ?] can't
see your laptop screen on your
phone, I don't think.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: It would
be quit fun, though.
Anyway.
All right, guys.
I think we'll call it
to a close there.
[INAUDIBLE].
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
Well, Happy Holidays.
Like we said, this is the
last one this year.
We'll be back in the New
Year, at some point.
And we'll announce when.
But, yeah.
Thank you very much.
And have a good break.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Yes.
ALL: Bye guys.